- [Narrator] Opioids are
drugs that are prescribed
to treat moderately severe or severe pain.
Examples of these drugs
include hydrocodone,
oxycodone, morphine,
hydromorphone, and methadone.
Heroin, an illegal
drug, is also an opioid.
In order to understand how opioids work,
it's important to know
how your body feels pain.
The process begins
when something harmful
happens to your body.
Information about this harm is
converted to a nerve signal.
The signal passes along nerves
to your spinal cord and brain.
In your brain, the signal
is perceived as pain.
Opioid drugs affect how you feel pain.
They attach to structures
called opioid receptors.
These receptors are found
on cells in your brain,
spinal cord, and other areas of your body.
Opioids act on these receptors
to make you feel less pain.
These drugs also have different
effects in other areas.
For example, opioids act
on the reward pathway in your brain.
This causes a release of
a chemical called dopamine
that results in a happy feeling or high.
Opioids may also cause slower breathing,
and they may cause reduced
motion of your intestines,
resulting in constipation.
For most people, when opioids
are taken as prescribed
for a short time, they are
fairly safe and effective.
But these drugs can be taken in ways
that weren't prescribed,
such as taking too many,
taking them to get high, or
giving them to someone else.
Misusing these drugs can raise your risk
of developing drug tolerance,
dependence, addiction and overdose.
Tolerance means the drug is
less effective over time.
This can happen when opioid
receptors become less sensitive
to the effects of the drug.
As a result, more of the
drug needs to be taken
for you to get pain relief.
Dependence happens if
a person has symptoms
when they stop using the drug.
When the drug is removed or
withdrawn, you feel sick.
This sickness is called withdrawal.
Opioid withdrawal has flu-like symptoms
that include restlessness and anxiety,
muscle aches, inability to sleep,
watery eyes and runny
nose, nausea and vomiting,
stomach cramps and diarrhea,
and dilated or widened pupils.
Opioid addiction is a brain disease
where you have an overwhelming
craving for the drug.
You can't stop taking the drug,
despite the harm it may cause you.
Addiction is not the same as dependence.
You can be tolerant of a
drug or dependent on a drug
without being addicted to it.
Finally, opioid overdose is a condition
where taking too much of the drug
can cause life-threatening
symptoms or even death.
The symptoms of opioid
overdose can include confusion,
feeling very sleepy or not
alert, nausea and vomiting,
constricted or small
pupils, unconsciousness,
slow or stopped breathing, and death.
According to the Centers
for Disease Control,
over 100 Americans die each
day from opioid overdoses.
If you have questions about opioids
or if you or someone
close to you needs help
for an opioid use disorder,
talk to your healthcare provider.
- [Narrator] This
animation is brought to you
by the Nucleus Medical
Art Library or NMAL,
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and videos
created by Nucleus Medical Media.
To apply for a free 30-day trial,
click on the link in the description.